another time I made a moral decision was  when I was offered a little movie called  Avatar  I turned down and I will go down in  history as the person because Jim  Cameron called me he offered me 10 of  Avatar  oh God  you will never meet an actor who turned  down more money than me he goes I I if  you don't because this movie doesn't  need you it doesn't need a movie star at  all he goes the the the movie's the star  the idea is the star but if you do it  I'll give you 10 of the movie so but I  was in the middle of shooting The Bourne  Ultimatum and uh and he wanted to shoot  during our post-production and we always  needed more work in our post-production  and I and I needed to be around I needed  to be available to do more work in our  post-production and for moral reasons I  told him I couldn't walk away from this  thing that I'd spent all these years  doing and he really celebrated that  decision so at least I got a pat on the  back from Jim Cameron